photo pi une ville est insolente les
animaux de toutes espèces prédateurs
comme proies vivre ensemble en paix et
en harmonie besoin je suis venu dire
votre nouvelle voisine on est bruyant
c'est comme ça on s'excuse pas le
premier l'a pas officier de la police de
s'auto pis tune box est prêt à rendre le
monde meilleur
mauvaise nouvelle en provenance de cette
ville marquée par la peur que
pouvez-vous nous dire sur les animaux
devenus sauvages et ton en danger c'est
la priorité numéro un
stationnement je ne suis pas là pour
faire la potiche si vous échouez vous
démissionnez
je suis venu vous poser quelques
questions pour une enquête il aurait dû
engager un vrai flic pour leur tournée
vous arrête pourquoi parce que je t'ai
fait que si vous êtes un témoin
essentiel non celui identifié cette
plaque
d'accord je connais la tipp quand tu as
besoin d'un truc il assure que t'es pas
récent il faut qu'on travaille ensemble
pour résoudre les enquêtes
ce n'est que trente six heures il s'agit
pas de vouloir absolument quelque chose
il s'agit avant tout d'en être capable
je suis un vrai flic jamais montré
comptable et c'est vous les lapins vous
êtes tellement émotif
on peut être évoluer mais au fond de soi
on reste toujours des animaux arrête tu
vas décor jeu dur il est tout nu bien
sûr on a tous bien jusqu'en bas haut
la vie est un peu compliqué
on fait tous des erreurs à peu importe
quelle force d'hannibal vous êtes le
changement commence avec vos portes il
s'est acquis la voiture est la partie on
parlera du crime mr bean
c'est mister big qu'est ce qu'on avait
dit on ne refroidit personnes le jour de
mon mariage je dois le faire mon bébé
papa doit le faire